it is a problem of assimilating migrants
now the Europeans were always terribly
Superior when they looked at the United
States and America's race problems and
all the discrimination and the
difficulties and and so on well they
don't look so Superior now because
actually Europe excluding Britain Europe
has proved to be much less capable of
assimilating and absorbing large numbers
of migrants that America which is built
on migration or even Britain and one of
the problems that France faces Germany
has it to some extent too is that the
migrant population there first second
third generation particularly in France
are all almost one of a kind they are
nearly all of North African extraction
or origin or culture and they're nearly
all Muslim whereas if you look at the
British migration pictures incredibly
varied